Mike's channel 4 sky news broadcast the
hashtag battle for number ten was number
one global trend on Twitter that was
around nine p.m. last night just as
David Cameron and Ned Miliband were
kicking off their event joining me now
is carl miller research director at the
Center for analysis of social media at
demos to talk through the impact of last
night's program on social media let's
have a look first of all at the sheer
volume of online activity about the
battle here you can see nearly three
quarters of a million tweets between
eight o'clock and this evening and the
peak that was 228 thousand tweets about
what was going on an hour how big is
that for politics that's absolutely
enormous this was one of the largest
digital moments in British political
history of course it was only one
sixtieth of the commentary around same
Alex a departure from one direction but
this is larger than anything we've seen
before for any of the debates and can we
we've been looking at the causes which
party was dominating discussion and
fairly even although what a fatter
amount talking about David Cameron he
did start first but the peak was
actually for labor that's right so the
discussion continued for Cameron after
he stepped off the stage but but really
the the peak bear is is familiar band
right kind of at the beginning of the of
his appearance when he's a during the
audience Q&A but let's just have a look
at what the substance of what people
were saying Carl you along with demos
ipsos mori and Sussex University have
been separating the tweets out into
cheers & boos red and blue as we see
just explain this one a bit that's right
so here we can see is the lines go up
you're getting more cheers than boos on
Twitter as a line goes down you can see
you're getting more booze than cheers so
really as soon as a Cameron steps onto
the stage you can see that his blue line
begins to plummet he's hit with a really
hard first question you can't remember
the number of food banks in the UK and
his note this put chorus of digital
booze on Twitter immediately which
sustains really throughout a really
grueling grilling bye bye Jeremy Paxman
only really to recover as he manages to
move the discussion on to the economy
but but bear in
he's never really going over this
halfway mark so he's bet by met by more
boos and cheers during this entire
period he doesn't really recover much
all very long and you're considering the
audience Q&A he's still met by a lot of
criticism or Twitter indeed reaching its
lowest point during a question about
unemployment now he really only recovers
as he leaves the stage and EDD Miliband
you can see really quite incredibly is
getting more cheers & boos it's
something we won't don't really expect
ever to see on Twitter during these kind
of events and and amazingly actually
gets even higher when he moves from the
audience QA into the Jeremy Paxman
grilling and you can see that he does
his best right at the end of his
appearance when he kind of becomes more
aggressive changes his tactics and
issues is kind of galvanizing hell yes
so he's getting positives there he's
getting a lot of pods now what do we
know about the people who use Twitter
are they inclined to be critical of the
Conservatives or not and its really very
mixed we see we see strong a kind of
mentions of all the different parties up
to now there's lots of Tories on there
as there is labour the Twitter users do
tend to be younger so we certainly see a
kind of galvanized kind of a youth vote
really voicing or being most vocal on
Twitter overall this is another version
of Cameron versus Miliband a sentiment
there done by another set of researchers
and this is called they say done by
Oxford University and analyzes tweets
per second detecting things like anger
or fear but also humor and sarcasm and
what they say is that Miliband sentiment
profile is more jagged than Cameron to
sign a more extreme polarization his
passionate answers at the end of the
packs of an interview promote emotional
responses from the people tweeting so
that's really pick up or the same thing
as you were saying that more varied
feelings about Ed Miliband that's right
you can see that volatility there is
really high for Miliband so he's a
divisive vaguely splitting opinion
there's both lots of people cheering him
and also being in and let's just have a
look Carla at some of the tweets you can
read one the bottom because I understand
that Ben page rip sauce maury you're
working with Nick net from
I said well that's right so that that's
us and our colleagues it's us more--
really realizing that this is the scale
alone is significant here this really is
one of the biggest issue amendments
we've ever seen 246,000 tweets they're
over the duration of the of the debate
itself